- Des bagages bandonnés,
orphelins; on les compte
par centaine à l'aéroport
Montréal-Trudeau.
- Une valise bleue! Bleue!
- Alexandra Bergeron est revenue
de vacances mercredi dernier.
Six jours plus tard, il lui
manque toujours une valise.
- On appelle Air Canada,
on n'a aucune réponse,
personne nous dit trop quoi
faire. C'est l'enfer,er,er,
honnêtement. Fait que là,
on cherche à travers les valises
empilées de tout le monde.
- Ils ont tout perdu.
Toutes les valises ici,
ils ont juste envoyé les valises
sans les personnes, c'était
épouventable... Very bad.
- Vous, vous avez eu
de la chance parce que vous avez
recupéré vos deux valises?
- J'ai prié un peu, puis j'ai
trouvé les deux autres sacs.
- Ce passager, arrivé
de Tel Aviv vendredi dernier,
vient tout juste de retrouver
sa valise.
"Je pensais jamais la retrouver,
je ne m'attendais pas à la
trouver comme ça,
dans un coin, empilée
sous d'autres valises."
"Si vous pouvez venir ici,
venez, n'attendez pas après
les compagnies aériennes."
L'industrie touristique qui
reprend ses activités à vitesse
grand V avec la fin des mesures
sanitaires est frappée
de plein fouet par une pénurie
de personnel.
La situation a créé un effet
domino sur les différents
services
Air Canada, par exemple,
transporte quotidiennement plus
de 120 000 clients,
ivement à 23 000
il y a un an.
agnie ajoute avoir
des problèmes avec son système
de gestion des bagages,
ce qui force l'annulation
de certains vols etdes probdes .
S'ajoute à la situation
le manque d'effectifs
aux activités frontalières;
jusqu'à 3000 agentssupplémentait
disponibles.
MARC WEBER, président, syndicat
des douanes et de l'immigration
- Je ne comprends pas comment la
situation maintenant n'était
100% prévisible.
-Ottawa promet d'intervenir.
OMAR ALGHABRA,
ministre des Transports
"De notre côté, tout a été fait.
Il faut maintenant collaborer
davantage avec les compagnies
aériennes et les aéroports pour
trouver on aux retards
des vols et la problématique
des bagages. Nous avons besoin
de leur collaboration, affirme
le ministre des Transports."
Pour l'instant, les voyageurs
doivent s'armer de patience.
ICI Marie-Michelle Lauzon,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.